next time you're going to do something
like that tell me first hey youtubers
it's Charlie and it's time for our Game
of Thrones season 4 preview for Arya the
last time we saw her she was getting
some revenge for the events of the red
wedding so I really wanted to talk about
where she's hid it in season 4 and where
character is going after this moment
like I said in my other season 4
previews I won't be referencing too many
specific events but consider this minor
spoiler warning for seasons 1 through 3
so I've always felt like Arya kind of
represents everyone's little sister on
the show in a way that Sansa doesn't her
character gets darker and darker as the
show goes on and even though she wasn't
really what you would expect from a
fantasy princess and the first season
her characters had some really big
turning points a lot of people point to
the red wedding and say oh this is the
big turning point for all these
characters but I really think that Arya
is turning point in this path to
darkness was actually when she was at
Harrenhal it was the first time she said
her prayer out loud and that was kind of
where jaqen H'ghar told her that revenge
was possible it was within her grasp
although I do feel like if she hadn't
run into Jack and agar and learned about
the faceless ones she still would have
ended up at the same point so talking
about the future of Arya I think that a
lot of people who've read the books are
gonna be really surprised with season 4
and the fact that they're really
expecting her character to go to this
certain place and I don't think that's
going to happen just based on the new
characters that they've announced and
the castings they've made in the new
sets and locations they're not going to
go to this other new place I don't think
that that's going to happen till season
5 but what does that mean for her
character in season 4 let's remember
where she is in Westeros because that
kind of tells us where she might be
going next so she's at the twins at the
end of season 3 right now
so she's between the Iron Islands and
the Eyrie remember that even though the
characters have all kind of gone their
separate ways
throughout the show they've all kind of
run into each other and really in direct
ways sometimes without realizing it so
that means that Arya might run into some
of the other characters from seasons 1
and 2 and just not realize it so that's
also possible to one character that I
don't think that she'll be running into
again as season 4 is Gendry I'll talk
more about gander II in his own video
but remember he left season 3 at
Dragonstone so he's basically on the
other side of Westeros so I don't think
the Arya is going to be seeing him in
season 4 I know that disappoints a lot
of shippers but don't worry I'll talk
about Aria and Gendry
that kendry video I also don't think
that Aria is going back to King's
Landing either but the Hound is actually
trying to make money off of her so he
will be trying to take her somewhere
where he can ransom her but let me know
what you think do you think the Aria is
going to travel to the Eyrie do you
think she's going to travel north to the
wall or do you think she's going to go
somewhere else do you think she's going
to run off honestly I'm really expecting
the hound and Arya to stay together for
most of season 4 but I do think that
something will happen to cause her to
run away or leave the Hound
during the season like I said previously
I really think about the hound and Arya
is this unintentionally funny duo I
always wondered if the writers write
them that way or if it just comes out on
the page that way because the more time
they spend together on the show the
funnier things get although it's really
really dark and it's not meant to be
funny like when she got revenge for the
red wedding and the Hound just walked up
and said next time you're gonna do that
let me know first I felt like that was
one of their funniest moments together
and it was totally not supposed to be
funny
so Peter Dinklage and Jon Snow are
basically some of the most popular
characters in the show but I feel like
Maisie Williams the actress is actually
now one of the most popular actresses on
a game of Thrones outside of the show
mostly because of her amazing vine feet
she is like the new queen of vines if
you aren't following her on twitter
here's a couple of her best vine videos
they're hilarious and a lot of them
actually involves sophie Turner so it
gets really really meta you should have
follow her on Twitter so you can get all
our new vines she's most active after
they've finished filming so after season
four is wrapped you'll probably see her
doing a lot more funny stuff
but I've been asking all of you which
characters you want to talk about first
and by popular demand the next video
will be about Danny be sure to subscribe
to get that video I'll be sure to post
it on Monday in the meantime keep
telling me in the comments which other
characters do you want to talk about
first I'll be sure to add them to the
top of the list you can click here to
get my preview for Jaime as season 4 and
you can click here to get my preview for
tiering in season 4 thanks so much for
watching you guys are amazing
high fives
you